vanessa
yep kingpin all right guys we're going
to watch some new rock stars today can't
wait to hear this breakdown keep pin in
hawkeye and spiderman no way home now
i've heard rumors about kingpin
appearing in hawkeye but i've really
heard anything about spiderman no way
home so of course it's coming from eric
voss gotta check this out king voss
let's do it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and as marvel studios prepares for
a snowy new york christmas with hawkeye
fighting track-suited russians in
spider-man ghostbusting variant sinister
six villains new evidence has emerged
hinting at how both of these titles
could be coordinating to reveal papa
feige's secret plan to reveal in the mcu
faces from the netflix marvel world
vincent d'onofrio as kingpin wilson fisk
and charlie cox as daredevil matt
murdock are we looking at a christmas
miracle of wilson biscuits coming to
slam their head in a car door
never forget that to break down all the
new clues for kingpin's rumored
appearance in hawkeye as well as the
possibility he could be the mystery
sixth villain of spider-man no way home
and lay out the timeline of how many
advent calendar windows we gotta open
before we get to the fist-flavored
chocolate it tastes like blood okay
really quick i'm gonna wait to hear what
erik voss has to say i don't believe
kingpin would be the sixth villain of
the sinister six because usually
traditionally speaking kingpin is
usually one who assembles the sinister
six he's usually the the man behind the
curtains pulling the strings a little
bit here and there so that's why i
wouldn't think he's the
the sixth member but you know it's mr
boss always curious to see what he has
to say ever since netflix canceled
daredevil and its other marvel titles
and those film and tv rights have
reverted to marvel fans have been
begging feige to formally canonize cox
and dinoprio in a marvel studios title
after rumors of cox being spotted on the
set of spider-man no way home the
trailer did show someone meeting with
peter parker when he was in custody whom
many speculated could have matched the
soft furry arms of charlie cox playing
matt murdock here peter's defense
attorney now i argued that it would be a
bit weird for someone defending peter to
slam those files so aggro-like and that
this guy's body type doesn't really
match charlie cox's indeed when cox was
asked about this by comicbook.com he
confirmed i can promise you
those are not my forearms in the same
day in the same press junket even cox
also said i wouldn't want to ruin
something either way like yeah
do you know what i mean like so
it makes me a little anxious in that
regard
you know because i love each other so
it's a difficult you know so it's
difficult thing to talk about you know
all i would say is like
i guess
everyone myself included is just gonna
have to wait and see what happens
charlie cox what a guy just makes you
want to see him and then see you even
more and yes while you could totally
interpret these as a grateful actor just
trying to manage fan expectations while
not disappointing anyone it's also not
very hard to compare his denials to
andrew garfield's denials like his
recent appearance on jimmy fallon i
heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop it's just
impossible to know what to believe these
days in the world of nerd news okay hold
on a second i don't know if harry foss
knows this but there were people who
took screenshots of the imax trailer and
they show the guy's face and it is not
charlie cox's face it's i believe it's
the guy who says in the trailer your
drone's the one who's already
interrogating peter and they do show
that same guy walking into the
interrogation room and he doesn't have a
cane or anything like that which already
is an indicator that it's not the blind
lawyer matt murdock so yeah it's already
been disproven that that is not charlie
cox that being said i still believe he's
in this movie they cgied that actor over
him don't believe anything but the case
for kingpin just got way more compelling
with the hawkeye trailer which gave us
some actual evidence pointing at his
existence in this world the series is
confirmed to adapt the 2012 matte
fraction run of the comics so evident of
an influence that the series logo was
taken directly from the cover page of
that comic series which you don't often
see marvel studios do this show will
introduce
a group told you that the dracula
in which kingpin bids on a tape of clint
barton assassinating a dictator in the
case of the show in the mcu it could be
footage of barton slaughtering members
of that cartel in mexico or the yakuza
in tokyo something this world hasn't yet
publicly linked with clint barton and
therefore could be what scares him into
staying in new york in order to stop
kate bishop from moonlighting as that
ronin assassin figure actually if you
think about it it's a similar dilemma
peter parker now finds himself in in no
way home the public now linking his face
with war crimes but in this case clinton
barton actually did the stuff i mean
arguably
but you know enough to turn black
widow's stomach from finishing that
peanut butter sandwich there's also the
fact that this hawkeye series will
introduce maya lopez echo echo worked
for kingpin for a time in the comics and
her father was killed by kingpin and her
father has been cast in this series
maybe we can find some answers on
twitter
you thought we forgot but nope it's time
for a tweet down
over the summer something so pretty big
indicators that dinafria would be
appearing in hawkeye and when people
tweeted dinofreyo asking about it he
liked those tweets and then this week
when the hawkeye trailer dropped on
monday minutes later dinofrio tweeted a
poem about a three-legged dog which when
commenters asked if that dog was lucky
the pizza dog or if this meant kingpin
would return in the show or asking about
the suspicious timing of this tweet
d'onofrio liked those replies too now i
don't know if that means anything
celebrities tweet random crap all the
time and often just like the replies
without thinking and dinofrio did later
tweet that people might have been
reading too much into things and that he
just loved playing fisk on daredevil
really i'm more curious about the timing
of all this they asked him to tweet that
yeah i think you're right john i think
they must have asked him to not throw
him off yeah they please sent off the
trail man i mean you got lucky the pizza
dog in there it just seems like a likely
scenario like it could just be
coincidence sure but i don't know
there's just so many things
and he's in a position where he's not
the most visual of all the rumored
actors you know and i've i've said that
i think the mandarin and chongqi is my
personal favorite villain in the mcu but
if we're going to include the shows
vincent d'onofrio as kingpin is my
overall favorite villain from all of the
marvels so far so i would love them to
be in this spider-man no way home will
release right between hawkeye episode 4
and episode 5. now at first i didn't
know how much to read into that because
i assumed hawkeye was going to take
place on the first christmas after the
blip december 2023 which would be a year
before no way home just based on lila
barton saying this is our first
christmas together in years but a set
photo shows a sign that reads happy new
year
meaning this must be december 2024 so
either clint just like blew off his
family for christmas 2023 or lila is
full of crap but either way this
confirms it hawkeye is actually going to
be taking place around the same time
chronologically in universe that's fine
oh [ __ ] please also in the city of new
york that means that any city-wide
events that go down and no way home
should affect the world of hawkeye and
vice versa and we just cannot ignore
that both avengers here are being
motivated by publicity scandals on top
of all the clues i mentioned hawkeye
including the kingpin associated
characters of echo and attract suit
draculas and that footage auction supply
hawkeye looks like the first mcu title
to truly explore manhattan's criminal
underworld at least without the
influence of avenger level technology
and if you consider that spider-man far
from home removed that whole sequence
where spider-man fought the man freddie
crime family i mean this show looks
completely iron man free at least beyond
the footlights of broadway and famously
in the marvel world everything below the
skyline in new york is supposed to be
kingpin's turf now in no way home a
total of five famous spider-man villains
have been confirmed doc ock green goblin
sandman electro in the lizard a number
of rumors have said that there will be a
sixth villain that marvel is currently
keeping under wraps i think all that is
missing from this villain lineup is a
local with the smarts to rally them to a
cause of ruining the life of the
friendly neighborhood pest who keeps
costing him business someone like wilson
this so for hawkeye we gotta be on the
lookout for any signs that new york's
organized crime answers to someone up
top because if so and if marvel lets
vincent d'onofrio reprise this role
folks it's just a matter of time for
defense attorney matt murdock charlie
cox to come to the defense of honorable
vigilantes like peter parker and clint
barton i just think he will be a
different set of arms than those in the
trailer yeah i find that really
interesting because i know agents of
shield had a similar debuggle that they
had to run through after the events of
captain america winter soldier they were
not given a heads up about what winter
soldier was doing so then they had to
change the trajectory of their series
due to what happens in winter soldier it
would be pretty cool i don't feel like
it's likely though i think hawkeye's
just gonna do whatever hawkeye's doing
because we don't know if the timeline
will truly overlap with one another what
is the time span of spiderman no way
home like how much time is that going to
be covering how much time is hawkeye
going to be covering if let's say it's i
don't know let's say six episodes but it
all takes place in the course of a few
days you know maybe the timeline does
not overlap with it because as we've
seen with wanda vision and falcon winter
soldier they all take place like some
earlier some later that could just be
the case i don't see them wanting to
make it confusing or like people are
watching hawkeye maybe they haven't seen
spider-man no way home and they're like
wait a minute what the hell's going on
because they haven't seen right now i
want to keep it to just the show
absolutely and i don't think you
especially for hawkeye and kate but
you're introducing a new character and
you're giving focus to a character who
isn't one of the top avengers that you
think of i think spider-man would
overshadow all that but i think it would
be cool that if you do introduce kingpin
and hawkeye and you got charlie cox and
daredevil confirming that no these
characters will continue to live on the
marvel cinematic universe i love that
approach so all aboard the next theory
train i worship at the altar of mephisto
i bled into the kang gang now long live
the kingpin support new rock stars by
checking out our merch options at
boostersmerch.com follow me on instagram
and twitter at ea boss follow subscribe
to new rockstars thanks for watching bye
god you know i really do think boss and
the team at new rock stars is the best
of the breakdowns in the easter eggs i
think they're just like just their style
and overall they're my number one
favorite for sure no offense to my
friends who also
guys subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already subscribe to us
click that like button click the
notification bell we got a lot of marvel
coming in just the next few months can't
wait with so much to cover see you guys
soon